au ministre de l'intérieur et porte sur
l'immigration clandestine en guyane
monsieur le ministre la semaine dernière
une embarcation de fortune transportant
une vingtaine de passagers clandestins a
chaviré au large de cayenne
si certains passagers ont pu regagner le
rivage par leurs propres moyens avant de
disparaître dans la nature
il a fallu l'intervention de l'armée la
marine nationale et les pompiers pour
porter secours aux autres occupants
parfois très jeunes je tiens d'abord à
saluer l'intervention rapide des
militaires et des pompiers qui ont
permis d'éviter un véritable drame
mais pour combien de temps encore car
personne ne peut ignorer que la guyane
est victime d'une forte immigration en
raison de 7 378 km de littoral et ses
frontières fluviales avec le surinam et
le brésil à l'instar de ceux qui tentent
de traverser la méditerranée
beaucoup entrent en guyane au péril de
leur vie et nous avons déjà connu des
drames bien qu'attaché à notre tradition
d'accueil
nous ne pouvons cependant plus faire
face à cet afflux massif en effet les
structures d'accueil par exemple comme
les écoles déjà en nombre insuffisant
pour nos compatriotes ne peuvent plus
faire face les squats et bidonvilles
dans lesquels cohabitent l'insalubrité
la violence est souvent la mort ne
peuvent être le quotidien de nos
compatriotes
exaspérés monsieur le ministre nous
avons bien compris que les différentes
mesures prises jusqu'à présent pour
juguler l'immigration guyane n'ont pu
pleinement porté leurs fruits et que les
moyens mis en oeuvre pour garantir
l'éloignement des personnes expulsées
sont d'une portée limitée
face à l'étendue de ces flux c'est
pourquoi je souhaiterais savoir monsieur
le ministre comment le gouvernement
entend réaffirmer les pouvoirs régaliens
de l'état en guyane et ainsi mieux y
contrôler l'immigration clandestine je
vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole et communistes d outre-mer
monsieur sébastien lecornu
oui merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice vous avez rappelé les faits
terribles du 3 novembre dernier à mon
tour au nom du gouvernement je tiens en
hommage aux forces armées aux forces de
sécurité intérieure pompiers secours qui
se sont déployés avec beaucoup
d'efficacité
peut-être aussi informé le sénat que le
procureur de la république de cayenne a
ouvert une information judiciaire
r que une personne était placé en garde
à vue qu'elle est désormais en détention
provisoire et donc dire ici au sénat que
la réponse de l'état de droit c'est
aussi que la justice passera contre ces
passeurs qui est malheureusement encore
trop souvent vous l'avez rappelé monnaye
ses services ça pose la question plus
globale et vous l'avez dit de la réponse
de l'état en matière de lutte contre
l'immigration en guyane
il ya un enjeu que vous connaissez mieux
que quiconque que madame la sénatrice
c'est bien sûr l'échelle pratiquement
1300 km de frontières un département
français aussi grand que le pays du
portugal avec pour le coup et pour
autant une maîtrise de la frontière
inédite ces derniers mois et pour cause
puisque nous avons fermé la frontière de
manière totale consécutivement à la
crise du coc vide 19
jamais un gouvernement n'avait déployé
autant de force sur ses frontières
ce qui d'ailleurs s'est traduit en
pratiquement à 2500 refus d'entrer sur
le territoire français au seul premier
semestre de cette année contre retenait
un chiffre 111 en 2018
on voit bien que l'effort évidemment est
constant et qu'il produit ses effets
néanmoins doit pouvoir avancer encore
davantage sur sur ces sujets dans les
temps qui viennent la première chose
déjà c'est de reprendre harpie à haute
intensité on sait très bien qu'un des
motifs de l'immigration irrégulière
c'est bien sûr la question de leur
paillage depuis maintenant plusieurs
semaines le programme haarp y ait de
nouveau en fonction
la deuxième chose c'est bien sûr
d'améliorer la réponse sur l'action de
l'état en mer puisque lorsqu'on tient
bien les frontières
on a malheureusement des tentatives de
contournement c'est ce qui s'est passé
le 3 novembre dernier par le grand large
ça pose aussi la question de la lutte
contre la pêche illégale là aussi les
forces armées sont déployées avec des
instructions claires qu'il était donné
pour avoir des opérations spécifiques
notamment sont les embouchures de hip
hop mais seulement quelques secondes
dire aussi que bien sûr la coopération
diplomatique avec les états de la zone
compte tout autant en tout cas j'ai
demandé au préfet de guyane de réunir
les maires de votre territoire pour
informer l'ensemble des élus municipaux
notamment les nouveaux maires des
actions qui seront entreprises en la
matière merci